THE FEDERAL COURT.
SO
AM. KEEPIHE.UCH MORE COMIN
A CASE OEMNING THE SIN
NOT THE SINNER.
TH TWO TOPTOOURMSINT DINNER WIT
ANEMHE
T NATIONLEADER NIC
N CA MITCH
ONLY CONDEMNED THE
NATIONAL.HOH AVOIDED DOING FASC.
McCARTHY SIMPLY SAID SOMETHING
THAT TRUE.
>> INYANY TIME WITH NICK
FUENTES.
HE HAS
REPUBLICAN PARTYP CA
FOES CONDEMNED HW O HE
SAY HE DIDN'TK FUENTES IS
NO, HEOT CONDEMN
ATLL.
NOT ONCE
AND WHILE ITO  MAN'S MD, TELLIN
TH CERTAINLY HELPED LEADERCARTH
FORMER
IT SAL ISM WAS  NECRY THE FORR
T DONE SO HIMSELBY
ND NK
E NEVEOU T
FI
NOINE ANT SEMITI THREE FENE
R DINNER
ALSO, I DIDN'T KNOW CK
THEN FINALLYE SHOWS UP
KNOW.THREE PEOE.
HADN'T SEEN HETEMENT T
AXIOS YI ASE
MEH T WHOM
NET AND NG T.
AND ON FOX DIGITAL, HE SAI'T KNV
AND DID NOT CONDEMN THOSE VIEWSO
PRESIDENT CONDEMNED NICKTES.
NOR HAVE MANY REPUBLICANS
P OUT BY OR DINING  THE MANR ROS
FORMEHUTCHINSON
>> PRESIDENTO TEATIONALIST ATID.
FOR ITHED DENOUNCE THOSE
INDIVIDUR HATEL OR WITHOUT QUALT
CONTRAST THAT WITHODTCH
ACTUALLY TALKINGUT SAY IN THE
ANTI-SEMISY. WITT POINT OF VIEW
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATESTE
ES TROTTING OUA
LEAD MAR CAREFULBO WHAT HEIE,
WAS GENERIC AN
SOUL, S
TRUM HT EVEN RULE OUAN>> YOU SAO
ANTI-SEMITIC VIEWSIF DONTRWINS
REPUBLICANLD YOU
SUPPOR
.
>>Y AIN.
THER SIMPLY M IN THE BLICAN PAR
LEADERS IN THETY
SEEKING S.
>> S
ATTAINL BYFO NINNAMES.IEW WITH I
ADVISER, AND SCOTT JENNINGS WHO
PRESIDEN GEORGE W. BUSADNIOTT, ,
YOU SAIDOU EXPECTED HELD
CHECK THRE COMMENTING. ONE ABOU
TEMPERATURE OF THE PEOPLE THEY
REHECOMMENT.
SO COMMENTS HEADE.LF AN LI
WHAT DOES T THTE FOUND?
WELL, WHAT I
WOU B
E STENHEF THEIR
TODAI WAS RIGHT.
BOTH MADE STATEMENTS AND T PELE
LIKE NICK S AND THE
HATEFU HE TALKS GOG S NON THPUI
PARTY.
THEY BOTH SAID THAT.G E CONDEMN
ME KNOW WHAT H
G THERE.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN NING ANDS
TRUMP HASN'T CONDEMNEDD
SUSPECT  WON'T.
THPATTERN.
DUMB STUFF AND THEN HE OWVEGUA
THATNT
OT OF BLDONE THE R
McMcCARTHY, ANCLEARLY AND UNEQU
STATED, THERE IS N
THIS IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
WHEV McCARTH MADE SOME
STUF OR THBLN WAS CO THAT INDICT
HETIG TOK SOME LINE?
OR TRYG L TO
HAVING DINNER WITH WHITEEA
NATIONAL>> SAID WAOUT SAYING, T
AND I THINK , THAT
WAS THE BEST MD
ANPLOFT KNOW H MU CAN SAY, DNT .
>> RIGHT.
AN
NG SOMETHING U YR
LITTL VL CSROERE'S THE
N  ISN'TER
HESUOME SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
TRUMP'
TRUMP ERT GROUP OF,  S
GROUP OFTORS WHO ARE TE HIM.E F.
KINDS OF KNOTS HERE TO TRY TO
NOT MP, GHON ANTMI AND
SO HMAAKE HEOU AT IN
CIRQUE DU LEE TIME
LIS IS
NIGHT THH REPUBLICAN
LEADERS
P WING TODAY.
ABSOTE THAT.
AND THERATE IKE A MA HIS POSITIN
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT
TY COULDN'TAVBEENFORTHRHT IEMN.
S MOREOR
THE FACT OF THE S THAT FORMERN
WITH THESE FOLKS AND IT WILLTOD
THEN YOU'REVASIVE.
ANI
THEY'RE NATIES.
THIS IS THE SAME
SEEN FOR SOMMEI THINK THE GLACIS
AND TRUMP ISVU S EVN.
D IN TATD PEOPLERE